so the people from a Hunger Games came
to me and they asked me if I wanted to
do an experiment that would be related
to power generation and strangely there
is this one idea that I've been thinking
about for years and now finally I have
the chance to do it come check it out
positions here we go
yeah Dali lights we have a setup here
with two grain showerheads making two
streams of water now each stream is
going to pass through a set of coils
right up five where they're released and
then it passes through this wire mesh
down below now these two sets of coils
so this set of coils is separate from
this set of coils and they are each
connected to one of these balls here
once we get the water flowing we should
be able to generate a little electric
spark right here
there it is what's incredible is that
we're generating a spark which is
probably five to ten thousand volts it
would give you a decent little shock I
mean it's not actually dangerous because
although the voltage is high there's not
that much charge behind it so you can't
get that much current flowing and
current is what really does damage now
the question is how just out of this
setup where we have falling water and
some pieces of metal do we generate ten
thousand volts
well the way it works is that normally
water is perfectly neutral there's even
numbers of positive ions and negative
ions but as the water comes out of these
two showerheads sometimes there's gonna
be a slight imbalance maybe a little bit
more negative in this stream and a
little bit more positive in that stream
now normally that just kind of washes
out over time but not in this case
here's the ingenious part the mesh on
the left is connected to the ring on the
right so if this mesh becomes negatively
charged then so does this ring and now
that ring will attract the positively
charged water so this whole stream
becomes positively charged therefore
when it lands on this mesh this mesh
becomes positively charged as well which
means
over here is positively-charged forcing
the negative ions to be coming out of
this stream more and so what we have is
a clear separation of charge there's a
positively charged stream on the right
and a negatively charged stream on the
left if you look closely at the streams
what you can actually see is you get
more and more attractive to these top
coils and then the spark goes and they
reset so basically what's happening is
we're building up charge on these coils
and then when a charge gets big enough
it jumps across from the negative side
to the positive side and everything
becomes neutral again and the charging
process can start afresh it's a pretty
phenomenal piece of physics I mean it's
such a basic setup in yet it produces
this very impressive result this was
noticed over a hundred years ago by a
guy named Lord Kelvin so it's often
called Lord kelvins water dropper or
Lord kelvins rain storm it's a really
impressive phenomenon but you might be
wondering how much energy could I really
get out of this system
well to put this in perspective if you
were to charge your phone on the energy
generated by this setup it would take
six and a half years to reach full
charge so this is a very tiny amount of
energy generation that we're talking
about you know an interesting thing to
consider is where does this electrical
energy come from all we really have is
just falling water and and metal pipes I
want you to leave me your answer in the
comments below or make me a video
response